September is coming in strong on Netflix with
more than 30 original new shows, movies, and
comedy specials.
With that many selections the casual viewer
is going to have a hard time picking out new
favorites, so we went through everything coming
to Netflix in September 2019 to find the best
of the best.
Just because Sacha Baron Cohen is headlining
the Netflix original limited series The Spy
doesn't mean you should expect a ridiculous
comedy.
The star of such films as Borat and The Dictator
has always hidden social commentary beneath
his outrageous characters, but this time he's
tapping into his more serious side to portray
Israeli intelligence operative Eli Cohen,
who infiltrated the Syrian political system
in the early '60s before ultimately suffering
a public execution.
You can check out The Spy when all six episodes
land on September 6.
This drama about a murder at a prestigious
boarding school pulled in rave reviews when
it was released on Netflix in October 2018,
with critics calling it a "must watch series"
and praising everything from the pacing to
its deft handling of sensitive topics.
But for all that, Elite never quite gained
a foothold.
Maybe because it's a Spanish-language show?
Maybe because it looks like any other dime-a-dozen
high-school melodrama?
Well, don't let those surface impressions
slow you down.
Elite is a smart, brutal drama, and there's
never been a better time to check it out,
subtitles and all.
It's no surprise that Netflix bet their money
on a second season of Elite, which debuts
on September 6th.
English actor and comedian Jack Whitehall
brings an enthusiasm to the stage that's hard
not to get behind, and that same excitement
shows up in Netflix's Jack Whitehall: Travels
with My Father, which sees Whitehall and his
dad hit up exotic locales in an attempt to
bond with each other.
"I'm just trying to be a good son.
… He's a very nice boy, Jack.
He's just a bit thick."
Audiences got a kick out of the first two
seasons, which saw the Whitehalls visiting
South Asia and Eastern Europe, and fans of
the show are no doubt looking forward to another
comedic adventure with season 3, which arrives
on Netflix on September 6th.
What is The I-Land, exactly?
All we know is that the show happens on an
island, things get crazy, and someone's watching
it all go down.
Kate Bosworth is starring and the premise
sets up a group of strangers who wake up on
a mysterious island with no idea how they
got there.
Judging by the trailer for the series, things
take a hard left turn into chaos after that,
leaving these strangers fighting and running
for their lives.
There's a little sci-fi, a little horror,
and a whole lot of mystery, and you can experience
it all when The I-Land premieres on September
12th.
Funny or Die's Between Two Ferns with Zach
Galifianakis probably doesn't need an introduction,
but for the uninitiated, it's basically this:
Zach Galifianakis kind of interviews celebrities
on a low budget set that includes, believe
it or not, two ferns.
He's interviewed everyone from Barack Obama
to Bradley Cooper, and the results are always
hilarious.
"Are you nominated?
I, uh, yeah.
For what?
For best actor.
How's bragging camp going?"
It's high time the oddball web series saw
a revival, and we can thank Netflix for making
it happen.
According to Deadline, Between Two Ferns:
The Movie is being imagined as a sort of meta
mockumentary starring Galifianakis as a version
of himself who lost all credibility when Will
Ferrell uploaded Between Two Ferns to Funny
Or Die.
In a last bid to fix his reputation, Zach's
hitting the road with his show so that he
can finally become a real talk show host and
get everybody to stop laughing at him.
We can't wait to check it out when it hits
Netflix on September 20th.
In one of the most ambitious series Netflix
has ever offered, Criminal follows multiple
storylines across four different countries
- in four different languages - and they're
each their own show​.
There aren't many details out at this time,
but it appears that Criminal will consist
of 12 stories that mainly center around police
interrogation rooms in the UK, France, Germany,
and Spain.
David Tennant headlines the UK cast and the
whole shebang drops on September 20.
There's a killer on the loose in Netflix's
upcoming thriller In the Shadow of the Moon,
and it's up to a Philadelphia cop to bring
him to justice.
Predator's Boyd Holbrook stars as the police
officer who's leading the hunt for the mysterious
murderer.
His only clue is that the killer times their
crimes to the lunar cycle.
"Moon bike...what is that?
Moon bike?
I said a lunar cycle."
Dexter's Michael C. Hall has also joined the
cast in an as-yet unnamed role.
Look for In the Shadow of the Moon on September
27th.
American Horror Story co-creator Ryan Murphy
is back with a new show: The Politician, a
violent political comedy set in a California
high school.
Murphy is teaming up with his longtime AHS
partner Brad Falchuk to tell the story of
Payton Hobart, a teenager with dreams of one
day becoming the president of the United States.
Before he conquers the White House, however,
he'll have to conquer the politics of his
local high school.
Ben Platt starts as Payton, with an exciting
supporting cast that includes AHS veterans
Jessica Lange and Dylan McDermott, along with
Zoey Deutch, Bette Midler, and Gwyneth Paltrow.
Judging by the trailer, The Politician is
going to be a laugh out loud dark comedy.
"Think I should kill him?
What?
….yes, yes I do."
Look for it on September 27th.
Netflix is bringing out a handful of new comedy
specials in September.
Keep your eyes peeled for Bill Burr: Paper
Tiger, which sees the irreverent comedian
taking on topics that range from Michelle
Obama's book tour to his own marriage.
You can catch that on September 10.
On the 24th, look for Jeff Dunham: Beside
Himself for the only comedy hour with puppets
you'll ever need.
Well, except for Dunham's five other Netflix
comedy specials, that is.
Finally, September 30 sees the first Netflix
offering from English stand-up comedian Mo
Gilligan, a special titled Momentum.
That does it for all the great Netflix originals
hitting the streaming service in September
2019.
Now let's pivot to see what other movies and
shows are going to be worth watching this
month.
There are a ton of must-watch action movies
storming onto Netflix in September.
The streaming service is heating up its lineup
with 300 and Dante's Peak, for starters.
It's also bringing in two thirds of the Lord
of the Rings trilogy - The Two Towers and
The Return of the King.
All of those films arrive on the first of
the month.
And on the 26th, you can check out the martial
arts action epic The Grandmaster.
On the thriller side of things, look for American
Psycho on the first, which marks Christian
Bale's transformative role as fictional serial
killer and all-around whackjob Patrick Bateman.
Netflix is also adding Come and Find Me, a
2016 film starring Aaron Paul as a man on
the hunt for his missing girlfriend.
If you're more of a monsters in the closet
kind of person, you won't be disappointed.
September 1 sees the arrival of The Last Exorcism,
while the 13th heralds Head Count, a creature
feature about a shape-shifting monster chowing
down on a bunch of teens in the desert.
From slow-burning mysteries to tearjerker
dramedies, there's going to be something for
everyone in the drama category.
The month opens with Clint Eastwood's Oscar-winning
Mystic River, J.D. Salinger biopic Rebel in
the Rye, and The Lake House.
Most of what we're getting in the comedy genre
is stuff we've seen a dozen times, but that
doesn't mean they don't merit a casual rewatch.
Superbad is popping up on the service, which
was pretty much the comedy to watch in 2007.
Haven't seen it in awhile?
You may just find yourself McLovin it all
over again.
If you're in the right mood, you can also
look for You Don't Mess with the Zohan.
Both that and Superbad arrive on the first
of the month.
Netflix is bringing a ton of much awaited
seasons of network shows into the fold, which
is great news for anyone who watches TV exclusively
on streaming services.
Is it worth it to wait a year for the next
season of American Horror Story?
It never seems like it at the time, but now
that AHS: Apocalypse is slipping onto Netflix
on September 24, the wait feels a little more
bearable.
Other shows we can look forward to in September
include Season 9 of The Walking Dead and Season
3 of MTV's Scream, both on the first.
We're following that up with Season 9 of Shameless
on the 10th and Season 5 of Gotham on the
30th.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.